so where does all that leave Greece
enough vodka is the director of the
European Council on Foreign Relations
and joins me now mr. bunker thank you
very much for joining us first of all
what do you think is going to actually
happen this time I think we will see a
final night as a big bang in the ends
where the negotiators get in front of
the cameras at 4am and announced there
will be a deal so another long night
marathon talks bleary-eyed politicians
but in the end who's going to make more
of a compromise do you think EU the e
u--'s top diplomats or Greece's new
government that's the tricky questions
or it will be both I think it has to be
and at the moment it looks like that the
Greek government has to find a way how
to sell the deal to their people because
they are the ones who obviously have
their their restrictions at the moment
but you don't think it's going to be
history in the making the first eurozone
country to leave the block no I think we
will it's just another dramatic step in
this continuous series of muddling
through because both sides shy away from
fundamental reforms which put us here in
that situation the first place what do
you think a a deal is going to look like
a last-minute deal is going to actually
contain yeah I think that's very
difficult to say and my impression is
that in the end it will maybe not make
that much of a difference so it's really
because at the moment we're not so much
in the economic logic but we are much
more than a political logic here it's
about the integration project so
therefore the signal from both sides
okay we will play somehow to the rules
but continue with the integration
project that's what's all about it okay
so it's all about politics politics is
at play but how is this going to be sold
to the creditors because a deal whatever
it's going to look like could actually
have a hidden haircut no absolutely in
Edward so because there I don't see a
way without a haircut if it's a hidden
one or an obvious one but the
alternatives are clear on the table so
either you lose all your money or you
just lose part of it so and I think
creditors will have a very rational
approach that and say okay so then let's
take and keep with what we have okay so
you think that would be argument enough
for the creditors what about
for the people of the streets yeah
that's that's a tricky one as I said so
I think this is a challenge for the
Greek government on the one hand to
agree with their counterparts from the
institutions to on a deal and some kind
of transparency and a set of rules which
they will oblige to on the other hand of
course they will sell it as a victory
saying okay so we said it from the very
beginning we will not give in will not
be a victim of the troika and in a way
they have to to sailboat at the same
time and do you really think we're going
to get a decision this week that's the
that's the tricky question against or I
think we will but maybe there will be as
I sets or another extension but could be
just a couple of days because the
deadlines are very tight lots of tricky
questions at the moment mr. Byrne cut
back to you in a moment